le secrétaire d'état américain a
critiqué aujourd'hui les récents propos
de son homologue français claude
cheysson des propos qui dit-il ne
facilite pas la solution du problème
libanais monsieur besson avait déclaré
lundi à antenne 2 que la france je le
cite ne s'associera jamais une politique
qui débouche sur la division du proche
orient entre russes ou syriens et
américano-israélien fin de citation il
n'en demeure pas moins que l'offensive
menée par la syrie au liban sert les
intérêts de l'union soviétique
georges bortoli il ya 15 mois la force
militaire syrienne n'était plus crédible
dans la vallée de la bekaa les
israéliens s'étaient joués des avions
mig des fusées de tout le matériel
fourni et installé par les soviétiques
du coup les soviétiques eux-mêmes était
déconsidérée puisqu'il avait regardé
leur allié syrien se faire battre sans
lever le petit doigt pour sauver cet
énorme investissement militaire comme
leur fameuse fusée solaire est
aujourd'hui quinze mois plus tard la
syrie réarmer pèse plus lourd que jamais
les soviétiques qui sont plus que jamais
présents notamment dans leurs deux
grandes bases militaires ou les syriens
dit qu'on ne met pas les pieds
il faut dire que si le président syrien
hafez el-assad est pas un allié toujours
commode
il reste pour les soviétiques le seul
allié possible au proche orient avec
derrière lui un grand pays dont les
hommes et les femmes sont capables dans
les temps c'est fort militaire de
surcroît un pays riverains de la
méditerranée où la politique arabe de
l'urss pourrait-elle mieux se
manifestait une politique arabe qui a
repris du muscle depuis que monsieur
andropov à succéder à monsieur brejnev
et puisque les soviétiques ont repris du
muscle
les syriens ont repris du muscle aussi
et monsieur hafez el-assad par exemple
est aujourd'hui ouvertement le suzerain
des milices druzes au liban washington
s'aperçoit peut-être un peu tard qu'il
n'y aura pas de règlement au proche
orient sans moscou et c'est pour être en
position de force devant moscou si
possible que monsieur reagan fait tonner
ses canons au liban israël